Alex to kiss bye-bye young Conrad from
Stanford and they can tell us about
keeping the independence born and thank
you thanks a lot for the invitation so I
updated the title a little bit compared
to the program plan was to talk about
the piece of work with Nick Harvey and I
will still talk about it that's from
about two years ago and then I will talk
a little bit about a recent update that
we did with fuchsia here last few weeks
so so the topic is the independence
polynomial and how to compute it and
where it's from our two topics related
to this workshop I want to mention two
reasons why we care about these
questions the first motivation comes
from statistical physics and the
relevant model here is the Hardcore
model so this is a model where you have
a graph and you have some parameters
cassadee parameters associated with the
vertices and the possible states in the
system are subsets of 30 sees that you
have particles sitting on certain days
and the only configurations which are
allowed in this model are independent
cells the particles are repelling so
much that they they never want to be on
two adjacent for this that's our core
model and then we have a weight for each
configuration s we have a weight which
is the product of these runners slam
down and this gives us a certain
distribution over the possible states
right here where the probabilities are
proportional to these weights and we
normalizing factor which is the
partition function so well the Pearson
statistical physics and this is the
object of great importance the the
normalizing factors summation over all
possible states so have you already
heard us talk
there are several fundamental care about
this object the partition function in
some sense if you understand the
partition function then you know a lot
about the system you take the logarithm
of the partition function you start
differentiating it you can obtain
various macroscopic parameters of the
system and if something strange happens
to the log if you have a pole some its
points to something discontinuity in
your story is more complicated as we
just heard but certainly the log of the
partition function very important
concept
another important concept that we
already heard about as well is I will
call DK of correlations in this talk
against these long range interactions
anyway the question is it true that if I
tell you what is happening somewhere far
away in the system does it affect
significantly what is happening here or
not do these correlations decay
exponentially or how fast do they decay
so in the particular model that I
mentioned the hard core model it is now
quite well understood what is happening
for real positive parameters
what so when the parameter lambda let's
say it's the same parameter on each
vertex well it's a real positive number
there's a certain critical point or
something interesting happens which is
essentially they're determined by what
happens on a large D regular tree and
this critical point lambda C has the
property that if you are below it then
then you have BK of correlations for any
graph of degree at most T the maximum
degree at most D and when you are above
this threshold then there's no DK of
correlations in particular on the
infinite D regular tree so this critical
point is also interestingly related to a
computational question which is whether
you can actually compute this partition
function or no well you can never
compute these functions exactly but we
can hope to compute within someone PI 1
plus epsilon error and again there's a
sharp transition here in terms of
whether you can compute this function or
not at this critical point so this was a
seminal work of Dror White's where he
proved that up to this critical point
you can compute partition function by an
algorithm which very much relies on this
phenomenon of correlation DK and above
the threshold in the red area here it
becomes np-hard which was proved by
Onslow and Nike Sun so so we have this
computational phase transition here on
the positive real axis what this talk
about this talk is about it's more about
the negative regime and actually more
generally the complex regime so what can
we say about the negative real axis so
one thing is that on the negative real
axis you will actually see a root on the
positive real axis there are no roots
because it's positive coefficients but
on the negative real axis there's going
to be some root closest to the origin
and this actually happens to be
the closest complex route to the origin
which was by Scott and SoCal among many
other things they study the Meyer
expansion which is the Taylor expansion
the log Z from the origin and you get a
lot of nice properties here namely the
log of the Taylor expansion of the log
converges in this disk whose radius is
determined by the closest negative rule
there's another connection here which is
very interesting which actually led me
and Nick Harvey personally to this
problem next slide so the questions that
we are interested in here are where can
you compute this polynomial where could
it possibly have roots and what about
this phenomenon of decay of correlations
what does it actually mean for negative
the second motivation and the reason
that we came to this problem as the
lavas local lemma and this is a
collection which was elucidated in this
paper by Scott and so cow
so the lavas local Lamar may be many of
you have seen it it's a two and
probabilistic combinatoric switch tells
you that if you have a lot of events
which are not quite independent but the
the dependencies between them are
controlled somehow the each event
depends on at most D other events then
it's enough to assume that the
probability of each event is like 1 over
D 1 over E and D plus 1 that already
guarantees that the intersection of the
complements of these events possible to
avoid all these events even though you
have lots of them the bound is almost as
if you had just the events you just
applied the Union bound you would need
to assume that the probabilities are
bounded by 1 over n but this tells you
it's enough to assume that the
probabilities are toast 1 over e times
the dependency degree it's a beautiful
tool in an aurochs
you know that there's a bound here which
only says that the probability is
strictly positive it doesn't tell you
how large the probability might be and
indeed it might be very small so this
leads to this whole area of how you
actually find can be configurations that
satisfy this bound but I will not talk
about that here what I want to talk
about is the connection to the
independence polynomial so so here's a
slightly more general set up you have
some graph let's call it the dependency
graph and the vertices represent the
events and the edges represent the
dependencies
pairwise dependencies and the property
that we want to assume here is that each
event is mutually independent of all the
events which are non neighbors in this
graph so whatever conditioning you put
on the events are non neighbors it
should not affect this particular event
or it could actually affect it but only
in positive direction so here's a
slightly more general version of the
lavash local EMA if you have a
dependency graph and if you can put
variables on the vertices such that this
condition is satisfied then again you
have the same conclusion that
probability of the intersection of the
complements is non-empty and you have
some quantitative bound here which
however could be exponentially small so
this is the this is the version of the
last local EMA that is usually taught or
you have probably seen that somewhere
but there's another even more general
version which is Shearer's lemma which
is less known the reason is that it's
not so easy to apply but the beauty of
this lemma is that it's an if and only
if statement so this is the optimal form
of the lavash lucuma shears lemma tells
you that if you have a dependency graph
with given probabilities on the events
then the conclusion of the lavas local
EMA is true namely it's possible to
avoid all the events for any
configuration of events consistent
with this dependency graph that's the
case if and only if the independence
polynomial is positive when you plug in
the probabilities with negative signs
and more moreover it should be true that
it's positive on some path connecting
the origin I just chose a simple path
here from the origin to my point P which
is just the line thing so that looks
quite strange at first the the minus
signs are related to some
inclusion/exclusion going on it actually
makes much more sense when you think
about it more but the beautiful thing
here is that the negative root that I
talked about earlier the root closest to
the origin that's exactly the the limit
of applicability of the livox local EMA
if you fix the depends dependency graph
and you ask how much can i push the
probabilities on these events before the
local EMA stops being true that's given
exactly by this this closest negative
root
the questions that are motivated by this
connection are are the following one is
can you actually determine what this
threshold is at least approximately
probably we're not going to do that
exactly but if I give you a dependency
graph do we can we actually figure out
what is the optimal probability that we
want to that we can put on the events
bound for which the local I might still
true how can we figure out what that
optimal bound is the other point that I
actually did not mention which is also
nice is that the value of this
polynomial when I plug in these negative
probabilities that's exactly the optimal
lower bound on the probability of
avoiding all these events in some kind
of extreme instance so this is actually
the best lower bound so compute
computing this value means computing a
lower bound the best possible lower
bound on avoiding all these bad events
in the applications these are usually
something bad that you want to avoid so
that will be also nice if we could
compute this the last question is the
question of actually finding a
configuration which avoids all the
events and that's that's the question of
an algorithmic Lovaas local MI which I
will not talk about here but as you have
probably heard that's a very interesting
problem with oh and in statistical
physics actually people have also tried
to compute this negative fruit so I
don't know exactly what the physical
significance of the negative root is
maybe somebody here can tell me more but
people have tried to compute it for
example for the planar lattice it's some
number this is some very accurate
estimate of the number computed by I
believe the transfer matrix method this
is exactly the number that we we are
asking can we compute this number in
general
so so here's our first result and this
is to work from two to three years ago
oops
so okay so this result says that as long
as you are not too close to this
negative root you can compute the
partition function which means you can
compute this lower bound on the
probability of avoiding all the bad
events and so on and the way we do is
that do this is essentially by applying
the correlation DK algorithm of your
whites which I will describe and the
algorithm is pretty much exactly the
same the analysis is different for
several reasons which I will but I want
to say that this result can be also
obtained by a different method which has
been discussed here in this program
quite a lot which is the polynomial
extrapolation method suggested by barber
knock and this particular result was
done by Mattel and erects which relies
on basically looking at the logarithm of
Z and extrapolating from the origin are
using the fact that you can compute
derivatives some low degree derivatives
at the origin
in one difference why I want to compare
the two methods a little bit in this
talk one difference is that between 16
and 17 so in 16 we had a result where we
had Delta here 20:17 we square Delta
okay maybe not a huge improvement this
was relevant to an application that I
mentioned which is and we actually
estimate where the nearest root is this
result is about computing the values of
the point on right and if you can
compute the values we can also compute
derivatives so we can use Newton's
method essentially to estimate where the
negative root is but we get some blow up
there in the exponent we actually get
square root and so the square root Delta
leads to a square root and but if we had
Delta here we would get exponential in n
which is actually trivial so the square
root
us to get at least something non-trivial
but you're not very happy with that
result I will talk a little bit a little
bit on the next slide in terms of the
picture in the complex plane this was
the picture two years ago so now there
are some updates but two years ago what
did we know we knew that on the real
axis there is this critical point lambda
C up to which you can compute you have
an FPS above that it's hard and then we
have this disc which is determined by
the nearest negative root and also
Kalani's Goldberg and Stefan Co which
proved that below that a negative root
it's it's hard to compute the partition
function
the question of estimating where the
negative fruit is as I mentioned that's
related to checking membership while
checking membership and something we
call shears region here what this means
is exactly checking whether the
condition of shira's lemma is satisfied
or not so if I give you these
probabilities I give you a graph how
well can you check whether shears lemma
actually applies or not so it applies in
this region described here which we call
here is a region and what can we do
about this question well it's relatively
weak what we can do but actually I want
to post it here as a question can you do
better using some of these other methods
so what we can do is we can essentially
estimate the nearest negative fruit
within a relative error of Delta in
running time which is exponential in the
worst thing is this square root and over
Delta so it's exponential in square root
and it's at least something non-trivial
but very bad and as I mentioned the
square root n comes from this square
root Delta improvement that we were so
now let me return to the complex plane
so what do we know about the roots let
me say a few words about this
alternative technology that Sasha bardey
Ngoc developed and it has been very
successful here so the philosophy with
me call it barbie knocks - ah Sophie
doesn't mind is that pretty much
everything is determined by where the
roots are so if you can if you can get
from the origin to some place in the
complex plane with some reasonably
region which is not too thin avoiding
roots then you can also compute the
value there so if you can get there
while avoiding roots then you're fine
that's the philosophy and it's also true
in a technical and some technical sense
so
first application of this is that you
know we already knew from Scotland socal
that in this disk there are no rules so
that implies that you can compute the
independence polynomial in this disk the
exact parameters might be their analysis
for example there's this question of
square root Delta versus Delta but if
you ignore such details then basically
the fact that you are root 3 and this
disk just tells you everything but then
ok there was this other phenomenon that
was known which is that this critical
point means that we can compute on the
real axis up to this point and not above
now there's no root on the positive real
axis so it was a little mysterious where
this phenomenon comes from this was
essentially explained by Patterson Reds
and 20:17 who proved number one they
prove that there's some thin rectangle
not too thin but some rectangle around
the positive real axis between the
origin and the critical point almost up
to the critical point where you don't
have any roots so that's another
explanation for why you can actually
compute the partition function up to
this point because if you have a region
like this then you can use barbie knox
technology and you can transform this to
some disk or you can maybe you can do it
in different ways you can ensure weight
towards this point by composing a
sequence of disks or you can do some
extrapolation methods to get almost up
to this point and compute the value
there so that's that's the philosophy i
hope i'm lee and not only that they show
that there's a barrier the barriers this
red curve here which can be right and
the meaning of the red barrier is that
there could be roots arbitrarily close
to this red curve and in fact the red
curve is determined by what happens on
large d regular trees so for d regular
trees they prove that things are very
nice inside this red curve there
no roots you can compute the polynomial
there's even correlation decay but
outside this curve there might be roots
anywhere on the curve you could have a
root arbitrarily close to it and in a
remarkable follow-up work as acaba
Kalani's Goldberg and Stefan koubek
showed that indeed it's actually hard to
compute the polynomial outside of this
curve and we will hear about this in the
next talk so this so this was a pretty
compelling picture by the way the
infinite D regular tree but so far the
worst case in some sense in both
scenarios on the positive real axis this
critical point is determined by what
happens on the D regular tree the the
negative root is also determined by what
happens on a D regular so maybe this was
the right answer right maybe this curve
is actually the correct separation
between easy and hard another update was
bench and chikv re show that there's
this was a bigger quite a bit bigger
region where there are no roots so blue
means no roots red means there might be
roots very recently boys who is also
here show that actually there could be
roots inside the inside this
heart-shaped region so that's maybe a
little bit disappointing this nice
conjecture cannot be true and the
examples that he found are are still
trees but not regular the degrees vary
in a certain way as you go down the
levels you vary the degrees in a certain
clever way you can produce these new
roots so okay so the conjecture was not
true so now what is the correct region
so the latest update is that we have
some region we have some new region
where there are no roots I will tell you
but we don't have a very nice explicit
formula for it but
I'll show you the statement there's some
region that we can basically check
numerically what which points are in it
and which are not one thing we know for
sure is that it connects nicely to the
bench jabari region and the point by the
way I should say the picture is kind of
a limiting picture for large but 6d so
when I say PI over 2 D it means that for
each D you get some picture but in the
limit this is roughly PI over 2 D so we
get the same point it connects to their
region and it also touches the this
heart shaped curved quite nicely we
believe and that's something we can
actually prove I think I want to claim
that can prove it has the right behavior
near the negative root so when you look
at the behavior of the curve close to
the negative root the imaginary part is
a certain part of the real part when you
when you shift it imagine that this is
the origin the imaginary part is like
the real part to the power of 1 point 5
so we get actually the correct power so
so around here it's pretty tight but as
you move out there's a certain gap and
we know that the gap must be there
because there are some roots even here
in this which between the green area and
the red curve so I don't want to claim
and this is the very recent work with
Jewish that we literally in the last two
weeks so I don't want to conjecture that
this is the correct region I think
should be careful now but at least it's
some nice region all right so I want to
say a little bit about the techniques
there are two parts here so I will try
to split the time let me talk a little
bit about this older work some of you
might have seen it but there are some
points I want to make so any question
about the results any question about
this picture
what's the curve so I don't we don't
have a closed formula for the curve I
will tell you our state a theorem or
state a theorem which tells you what the
curve is but we don't have a nice
formula yeah it's so so actually I drew
it by the way this is a sketch this is
not an exact plot
I drew it as if the derivative here is
the same but I'm not sure if we know
that we don't we don't want to claim
that yeah it's it's the same value at
least but not you're about the
derivative any other questions about the
picture
so let me talk a little bit about this
work from two years ago so what was the
point there so it's it's a correlation
DK algorithm which by now has been used
quite a lot is it the new there are a
few new aspects here one is that we have
multivariate polynomial here so so this
is a polynomial where you have a
different value sitting on each vertex
that was actually the main difficulty
the question of what we could possibly
expect here in the exponent is very much
relevant to the application that I
mentioned which is how well can you
estimate the negative rule fortunately
for this method we know that square root
Delta is the best we can do here so that
happens sorry 1 over square root Delta
is basically what happens on the the
irregular tree if you look at the
recurrence and see what happens in the
negative regime it converges with a rate
which corresponds to this 1 over square
root Delta so that's the best week we
cannot improve that
how we analyze the correlation became
algorithm is is a little bit new so let
me recap very quickly how this algorithm
works and this is work of drawer whites
where he did it in the positive regime
you write down the partition function as
a telescoping product of these ratios
the ratios can be interpreted as ratios
of certain probabilities basically for
certain subset of vertices certain
induced subgraph you look at the
distribution of independent sets and you
look at the probability that this vertex
appears versus probability that it
doesn't appear and the ratio gives you
something we call our sub su and if we
can compute these numbers then we can
compute everything so let's focus on
computing these ratios now these ratios
satisfy a nice recurrence formula which
is that for any per text you and when my
current subset is s I can look at the
neighbors of U and I can peel them off
one by one and I get this product I get
lambda which is the parameter here at U
times
product of 1 over 1 plus the ratios
corresponding to its children so if we
could unroll this up 2 down to the
leaves then we would compute exactly
these ratios but obviously that the tree
would be too large so so the idea here
is to cut off the tree just chop it off
at some level and hope that it doesn't
mess up the computations too much and
the question whether this will affect
the computation there too much is
exactly the question whether you have DK
of correlations or no for these
quantities so Weitz's great contribution
was that you sure that you actually have
DK of correlations in this computation
the errors will just disappear if you
choose the depth to be sufficiently
large like it's enough to take
logarithmic and he showed that that true
up to the critical point which was
already known conjectured to be the
right answer
so so we want to do the same thing in
the negative regime actually the fact
that we have negative parameters it's
not such a big deal
it doesn't change things too much what
is new here is that parameters are non
uniform so so the difficulty here is
that we have a recurrence which looks
exactly the same I just flip the sign
here because of the negative regime and
and we have a certain parameter now I
call it PU because it corresponds to the
probabilities that I talked about
earlier this PU is some parameter
sitting on each vertex and I don't have
any uniform bound on these P use it
could be some probabilities and I only
know that globally they satisfy this
property that the point that we are
evaluating is not too close to the
negative root it's like some it's some
global property but we cannot say
anymore that as we perform the
computation and we go up one level let's
say we cannot prove that the earths will
decay by some factor it could actually
blow up and then decay again and blow up
depending on the structure of the graph
and structure of these parameters so we
need some more more flexible notion of
what it means to have DK of correlations
and this more flexible notion this is
this new notion is that we define a
certain yardstick for each vertex in the
graph or in the in the computation tree
rather we define a certain parameter
that we want to compare ourselves to and
that's that's this quantity beta so
imagine that I can define certain
parameters beta such that I can prove
that the true values differ from the
values that I estimate by something that
DK is relative to these betas these
betas should also be somehow reasonably
behaved in the sense that they don't
blow up if these betas blow up then this
doesn't mean anything but let's say I
can define the betas
in a reasonable way and get a guarantee
relative to to them so the question is
what should this beta be and it happens
that there's a pretty nice way to define
it which works very very well and the
way you can define the betas is that you
just take derivative essentially a
directional derivative of the parameter
that we want to estimate the RSU on a
line that connects the origin to that
imagine you draw a line from the origin
through that point and you move along
that line and take the derivative when
you are at the point of view derivative
that's my parameter so I claim that this
is somehow the right notion why is it
the right notion I think this might be
applicable more generally because
something that happens here is pretty
generic what happens is that we have a
certain recurrence right the recurrence
the recurrence was here this is a
recurrence we compute recursively these
values and then we want to compute this
one the question is how do the errors in
these guys propagate to an error in this
one well if the errors are infinitesimal
we can we can do an engineering
approximation we can say that the errors
propagate like this we take the total
differential by the chain rule you get
this formula this formula is very
different to taking this direction on
derivative actually there's one
difference which is this one plus but
apart from that it's exactly the same
formula the one plus comes from
differentiating the this PU in front
itself but let's ignore that it's
exactly the same formula and that
there's a generic reason behind the
chain rule how do you how do you
differentiate a function of multiple
variables you differentiate it like this
so so this tells me that if things were
infinitesimal if the errors were
infinitesimal then they would propagate
exactly according to these betas that
this is the correct definition of how
errors propagate in this computation so
then all we need to do is to analyze
these betas and say that they are
themselves not too large so that
requires more work but I will skip it
I'll skip the details this is basically
the
of analyzing correlation decay in this
multivariate setting which was I think
it's new questions about this or I will
move on to the last part which is the
new part yes yes good question no so we
don't know that we we certainly didn't
have time to explore it but it's a good
question one one point so the green
region which I will turn to now it's all
about the single variable regime so
there are two regimes here univariate
and multivariate to be fair I should
also say bit about your technique the
polynomial extrapolation technique seems
to be able to handle multiple variables
which means non non uniform assignments
somehow for free right because you take
univariate restriction along the line
through that point and somehow it just
works for free while here we have to
work quite a bit to make it work so so
that's another advantage of your
technique I think the only advantage
that we still have is the square-root
elta the last surviving unless unless
sasha can do it now but so yeah the two
techniques are kind of related but still
not quite so there's something
interesting too very similar yeah well
but in our setting it's a little bit
more involved so as I said it's a
contraction under there there are
different ways that people do this
either they they map they have some map
which will transform the complex plane
in a way that will make your recurrence
of contraction what we are doing here is
a little bit different it's we define
these betas maybe you can interpret it
that way too but I'm not sure but the
main point is that this is a
multivariate setting which is quite
different from all these other papers I
think those are all
multivariate for matching monomial
matching and it's it's multivariate so
let's talk about it alright so I have
five minutes I guess five minutes for
this new latest piece of work so okay
this is I can formulate a theorem which
you might find satisfying or not so this
is the condition that we have so we were
interested in what happens in the regime
of complex parameters and now back to
univariate Z of lambda just one complex
parameter and the real part of lambda is
negative so we are in the left half
plane what happens there
so so this is what we can do take some
lambda in this in this region and
generate a certain curve the curve is
generated in segments the first segment
is just a line segment so you draw from
the origin to lambda a linear segment
and then we apply repeatedly this
recurrence which is every time there's
some paper on roots of the
anti-dependence polynomial this comes up
this is always relevant so now we apply
it to the previous segment of the curve
and we map the previous segment of the
curve under this map and we continue
doing that the statement is that if this
curve is contained in the upper half
plane then lambda cannot be a root as a
theorem like you could ask how effective
is this or how can we check anything
using this property the thing is that
you don't have to generate the curve all
the way to infinity including one
example of
what happens here so the the heart
shaped curve is what we saw before
that's the the red curve cardioid it's
not quite a cardioid that's the same
curve as before this curve is the G of T
curve that I described so it starts with
a linear segment
sorry it's a pretty ugly picture
generated this is like four or five
segments that you need to generate
before you see that you didn't enter the
negative the lower half plane and in
fact the argument of Z as you move along
the curve started already increasing so
actually you can say at this point you
can say safely that this curve will be
trapped in its own orbit and it will
never generate anything that's outside
of the convex hull what we have seen so
far so this is how you can check that
things are fine so this is one example
of a lambda for which we can say okay
there's no root there cannot be a root
at lambda because the curve behaves like
this so why can we why can we say that
the the important point here is the the
interplay between multivariate and
univariate again so in general we should
worry about the multivariate recurrence
we should worry about what happens when
we take some some values z1 through ZD
minus 1 and we apply this recurrence
this is exactly the same recurrence that
we saw in the and Weitz's algorithm and
in our algorithm as well lemma which is
pretty easy to prove which was used
before is that if this is a root for a
certain graph of degree at most T it
means that it's possible to generate
minus 1 using this pricker if you apply
it one more time then this is divided by
0 so something bad happened there but if
it's not possible to generate minus 1
that it means that this cannot be root
this is a fairly
and usually the difficulty in analyzing
this is that you have to deal with
multiple variables you have to keep
track of what maybe you want to find
some region of the values Zi that could
be possibly generated by this recurrence
and if you can show that that's bounded
away from minus one and you know that
you are safe so one thing we do here is
that we actually considered slightly
more general recurrence where you are
allowed to put fractional powers here
makes things more smooth so let's allow
to have more than D parameters but we
always raise them to powers that add up
to at most D minus one just allow that
one thing that this implies is that if
you can generate z1 and z2 then you can
also generate any geometric convex
combination if I can call it do you want
to the alpha times z2 so this makes the
arguments more smooth this one
elementary lemma that we have to prove
probably it should have a simple proof
but anybody who knows a trivial proof of
this tell me after the talk for any two
points in the complex plane when I
connect them by the curve of these
geometric averages in the sense that
convex combinations between these two
points are always
this is useful in our analysis and I
should propose that the point here is
roughly speaking that in this
multivariate recurrence we can always
reduce things to a single parameter
which in some sense dominates what we
could generate by using multiple files
and if there lies exactly one is this
geometric lemma that I just described
the claim is that whatever you can
generate by using this multivariate
recurrence you can also generate by this
univariate recurrence where Z tilde is
something in the convex hull of these
guys so you can always replace things by
points in the convex hull and you can
always generate something that the same
argument and modulus which is at least
as large and that's what you need to
track what is the maximum possible
modules that you can produce for given
once you have that property we can prove
this that if the curve that I described
is a contained in the upper half plane
then this cannot be a root and it all
relies on the fact that we were able to
reduce things to this univariate case so
so we can check for different points
whether they could be roots or not we
can do some analytic computations but
one thing I I believe it's correct but
this is very fresh so let me state it I
believe that we have the same power law
near the negative root which is given by
the cardioid root which is the imaginary
part is roughly the real part to the
power of 1.5
okay so let me finish with few open
questions I mentioned some of them
already I think so is there any way to
compute the independence polynomial with
a better dependence on Delta which is
the distance from the nearest to it
pretty bad it's 1 over square of Delta
in the exponent and that essentially
kills all the applications that we
originally were hoping for like some
algorithm for de lavaz local EMA that
basically failed because of this reason
another question for estimating where
the negative terminal yeah a question
that some other people here are also
thinking about is what is the maximal
route 3 region the question of the
picture that I showed what is the right
picture and one more question I want to
mention which I don't know if it makes
sense curve is assist but the sheera
region in the negative version is a
multivariate region and it has some nice
description and a nice interpretation so
is there actually a meaningful
multivariate region for positive lambda
like like the Weitz's threshold but but
you have different lambdas on different
vertices is there some nice region where
you can compute D in the positive real
regime multivariate sense does it mean
anything ok so that's all
[Applause]
so I have actually get the philosophical
question is there a relationship that
will lose this stuff including by the
way that interpolation of method and
method of transfer functions can I kind
of prune matrices and the transfer
function make them smaller based on
their contraction properties and
together together you know because the
reason why I'm asking it when I'm
listening to this
the people who interested both roots of
polynomials multivariate so we know
physicists we know this community but
it's also there is also control theory
community which talk with so called
D dimensional systems and I look at the
things which you do it it kind of
reminds me with whatever is that the
philosophical question can you give you
also blue transfer function method based
on the spectral properties of where this
is then is the connection I have no idea
yes so this the world of the
independence polynomial is not not very
spectral like we don't talk about you
know no matrices and eigenvalues here
there's a connection possibly to the
Catalan singer world that we were at
some point hoping to find that that's an
also not clear so that that's the
spectral I don't know this is a little
bit different I don't have any time
Oh Oh so you mentioned whites Albay or
whites whites approach but you mentioned
only in the context of decay of
correlation whites oh look at this very
nice algorithm for rightful computing
partition function is any connection
between his algorithm and not use of it
forward to calculation and polynomial
but this algorithm is exactly what I
described right it's that what
instruction this self avoiding fee yeah
let me say a little bit so the way
drawers describes things it's a little
bit different he talks about this self
avoiding and walk tree and he compares
what happens on an arbitrary graph
versus this tree so this is a slightly
different point of view which is
actually equivalent so uh I prefer not
to think about self avoiding walks I
think it's easier like if you look at
this at least in the regime that we are
worried about this recurrence here and
something these are exactly the self
avoiding walks if you track you started
some subset you go to a child you always
have to peel off the parent so the
branch is in this tree you can interpret
them exactly as so providing walks it's
just a slightly different notation but
it's actually exactly the same tree that
mean
we just use a slightly different
notation but it's exactly the same thing
and we analyze things directly on this
computation tree we don't yeah I think
it's just a matter of how how you be
with it's not myself avoiding P is very
uneven right branches so if your
question how that affects the
computation on the tree or the question
that we are interested in is how the
errors propagate on this tree and that's
also the question that drawer is cares
about it's exactly the same question
yeah I'm not sure we can talk upon yeah
yeah yeah
we have a slightly longer break where we
can mean that at 11:25